investigators hope for Pennsylvania men
who mysteriously vanished are alive a
huge search is underway on this farm
north of Philadelphia now it belongs to
the parents of a person of interest
Cosmo DiNardo he was released last night
after posting 10% of his one million
dollar bail for an unrelated weapons
charge DeMarco Morgan is outside the
property a new hope with how the strange
disappearances that rocked the community
DeMarco good morning good morning nor
the district attorney says the search at
this farm is the largest of its kind in
the county's history
he hasn't revealed why they are focusing
on this location but he's confident
investigators are on the right track
this picturesque part of Pennsylvania is
one of the safest in the state but the
disappearance of the four young men has
shocked the community it's frightening I
have a 20 year old and I'm concerned
what what happened to these boys nearly
100 state and local police have been
joined by FBI agents and US Marshals in
the all-out search they are using
everything from hand sifting tools to
heavy equipment says Bucks County
District Attorney Matt Weintraub it's 90
some acres and we're going through it
with the equivalent of a fine-tooth comb
families of the missing have been
keeping vigil on the edge of the farm
cadaver dogs have been brought in but no
human remains have been found
investigators are clinging to the
possibility the missing men are still
alive I have hope I think that it's very
important to hang on to hope until there
is no room left for it 19 year-old Jimmy
Patrick a Loyola University freshman
disappeared last Wednesday dean
Finocchiaro 19 mark Sturgis 22 and Tom
mill 21 vanished
two days later 20 old Cosmo DiNardo who
was arrested Monday on an unrelated
charge has not been named a suspect
police say he suffers from mental
illness I want to be very careful to
stress that he as a person of interest
officials have not said if all the men
knew each other
DiNardo lists Patrick as a friend on
Facebook Sturgis and Mayo are close
friends in real life I'm all shaken up
about it
Walter Moore Zukowski is a friend of
Jimmy Patrick who scared
we just want to know we wanted we want
to know something because we're all
world it's we don't know we are very
worried I'm very stressing out over them
Nicholas Salguero is friends with both
male and Sturgess he says he never heard
the mentioned in our doll's name we hope
that they are doing their okay and
nothing bad has happened to them
sturgess's father to the Philadelphia
Inquirer that his son's car was found
about a mile away from the farm Tom
Mills vehicle was found at another
donato property nearby and the DiNardo
family and his attorney have refused to
comment
gaile very strange story thank you very
much DeMarco